direct alexis poule un autre
éditorialiste alexis apoula un bon jour
malheureusement j'ai eu une guerre on a
un peu l'impression que l'histoire se
répète en ce samedi promis mais tout à
fait on a l'impression que depuis qu
emmanuel macron le président le 1er mai
devenu un théâtre d'affrontements entre
les préfets l'état la police et les
manifestants alors qu'avant cette fête
était une fête familiale où on célèbre
bien sûr les valeurs du travail mais
aussi les luttes sociales toutes les
avancées qui ont pu arriver parce que
justement les travailleurs se sont unis
à année après année pour faire avancer
la république sociale et là on voit
depuis 2010 est ce 1er mai totalement
défiguré par une sur présence à un
policière qui fait qu' évidemment ça
dégénère puisque les tensions sont là et
puis on oublie pas le mouvement de gilet
jaune comme vous l'avez montré dans vos
reportages qui portent les mêmes
revendications c'est-à-dire une vraie
démocratie où on va enfin consulter le
peuple où il va être enfin représenté et
puis de l'égalité de la justice fiscale
tout ce qui fait défaut dans la
république des mallettes macron
actuellement alors là on parle de
quelques 5000 policiers à présent cette
manifestation on n'a pas de chiffres
précis en tout cas des manifestants
présents à paris mais quand même
cent mille policiers pourquoi un tel
dispositif pour cette manifestation
parce que comme je viens de le dire le
pouvoir aujourd'hui est à l'affrontement
systématiquement et mal maintenant on
disait il ya peu que ea nous sommes en
guerre mais cette guerre elle est de la
guerre du gouvernement contre son peuple
ce peuple de gaulle warax facteur c'est
gilet jaune qui n'ont jamais été
entendus le grand débat n'a été qu'une
grande fumisterie ou mails macron s'est
mis en scène enterrant les cahiers de
doléances qui dorment maintenant au sous
sol de la bibliothèque nationale de
france et on voit bien que les
revendications pas changé les problèmes
n'ont pas changé finir le mois est
encore plus compliquée d'ailleurs avec
les faillites nombreuses qui risque
d'arriver avec la précarité qui continue
un français sur six sous le seuil de la
pauvreté
ce n'est pas anodin on nous rabâche
quotidiennement les chiffres des morts
dus qu'aux vide on oublie les chiffres
des chômeurs de longue durée qui ont
explosé en oublier les chiffres de la
précarité qui ont exposé ses étudiants à
qui on a peu donné la parole certains
qui se sont tués parce que trop précaire
les fils qui s'allongent devant les
banques alimentaires cette france qui
sombre finalement dans un déclassement
internationale dans
chaos non assumée par le président de la
république qui lui parle réouverture
politique qui veut faire croire que tout
va bien quand tout va mal tout va très
bien madame la marquise sauf que voilà
quand on manifeste dans la rue on a
affaire à un mur policiers un mur de
grenades lacrymogènes et ça va le faire
qu'empirer dans les mois qui viennent
parce que cette grogne sociale elle
n'est plus une grogne
elle est maintenant une revendication de
plus de république de plus de démocratie
or nous avons tous les reverse proposée
par le pouvoir et le gouvernement
présence est ce que finalement cette
crise sanitaire à creuser le fossé
l'écart entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres totalement cette crise
sanitaire a fait exploser les inégalités
et c'est un sujet jamais abordé ni par
bruno le maire ni de l'économie ni par
elisabeth bornes ministre du travail ni
par ailleurs le maquereau quand vous
écoutez le gouvernement les ministres et
le président vous disent qu'il faut
continuer le chemin des réformes c'est à
dire continuer la casse de l'assurance
chômage continue et la casse des
retraites faire le moins disant social
parce que c'est ça que veulent europe
c'est ça que veut le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron alors que tout va mal
alors certes nous avons un peu de répit
excusez moi avec l'aide
enfin le plan de dette européens la
dette qu vide mais en réalité cette
dette va précipiter encore d'autres
entreprises dans l'est dans la faillite
ou dans la difficulté de paiement et on
voit bien que il y à une dystopie
terrible entre ce que nous propose le
gouvernement est ce que vivent les
français au jour le jour la réalité la
peur du déclassement la peur de la perte
du travail
ces entrepreneurs restaurateurs et
autres monde du spectacle qui luttent
combien de lieux aujourd'hui une
centaine de lieux occupés à marseille le
théâtre de la criée devenue une
assemblée générale on a l'impression que
le pays est en train de bouillir c'est
une cocotte-minute caché par la plupart
des médias sauf rt france merci pour
votre travail
la réalité c'est que ça va très mal que
les français le savent et que en haut on
nous dit que ça va très bien or cette
dystopie ne pourra tenir qu'un temps
alors ils veulent faire tenir bien sûr
quand je lis il sait le gouvernement les
politiques en place jusqu'en 2022 pour
que le jeu puisse se mettre en place
mais on voit bien que tu es qui lie à
une manifestation dans la rue dès qu'on
va voir la réalité des français c'est un
français sur six dans la misère et bien
là il n'y a plus personne
il n'y a que du mensonge un village
potemkine une mise
scène finalement du pouvoir qui est
complètement indépendant de la réalité
et qui n'a aucune prise finalement sur
cette réalité puisqu'on attend ces aides
européennes sans pouvoir appuyer sur un
quelconque boutons ou faire bien sûr de
la dette nous avec une monnaie
souveraine
donc on est totalement tributaire du
choix de la commission européenne
justement où en sont les acquis sociaux
des travailleurs français
il vient de le rappeler très justement
ces acquis sociaux sont menacés puisque
il y a à la fois la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui précipiterait
plusieurs environ un million de
locataires dans la précarité avec la
baisse de ces allocations la limitation
dans le temps alors même que
l'incertitude économique demeure avec
cette crise sanitaire qui va devenir qui
est déjà une crise économique
et puis il y a c'était en des retraites
qui est la réforme systémique un
demandée par bruxelles pour les aides
justement porté par bruno le maire qui
fera tout pour que cette réforme arrive
même si ce n'est pas en 2022 ce sera peu
importe qui va être élu en 2022 il
faudra continuer il faut que la france
suit ce chemin des réformes imposées par
bruxelles pour l'harmonisation du moins
disant social au niveau repères donc on
voit bien que alors qu'il a fallu se
battre alors que vous sortir de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
justement le parti communiste français
les syndicats avaient réussi à imposer
une république sociale celle ci a été
rogné systématiquement gouvernement
après gouvernement et emmanuel macron
voudrait finir le travail
arriver à faire en sorte que la france
s'aligne sur l'allemagne c'est à dire
les lois ars avec le guichet avec le
choix de la pauvreté de masse le travail
sous payer les travailleurs pauvres qui
doivent cumuler plusieurs travail pour
pouvoir vivre
c'est le cas des états unis on se
félicite ici en europe du plan buydens
en lisant cet incroyable il dépense de
1000 milliards mais que fait joe biden
il essaye de se remettre à niveau de
l'état social qu'est l'état français par
exemple avec une éducation gratuite
obligatoire plus longue avec des droits
sociaux élargie avec de la taxation des
plus riches et que fait une belle macro
et bien tout linverse sous prétexte
qu'il ne faudrait pas taxer les plus
riches parce qu'il partirait mais quelle
est cette ce logiciel ce choix de penser
c'est un choix archaïque 1 c'est celui
de margaret thatcher qui avait fait ses
réformes dans les années 80 ou de ronald
reagan de dire qu'il faut toujours que
les plus grands
s'enrichissent et que les plus pauvres
trouveront un travail sous payés ou
quelque chose et qu'il y aura d'une
façon ou d'une autre le ruissellement or
joe biden a dit le ruissellement ne
fonctionne pas et mac on sait très bien
mais lui continue s'entête à ne pas
vouloir créer de nouveaux impôts en
disant que si jamais on devait taxer les
plus riches alors on en viendrait à
taxer les plus pauvres c'est faux c'est
un une pirouette sémantique
en réalité il est là pour préserver la
richesse qui s'est accumulée pour les
milliardaires mondiaux
elle a été multipliée par deux en 2002
20 grâce à la crise sanitaire
pour eux ça va très bien pour les
travailleurs ça va très mal et ce 1er
mai d'ailleurs est symbolique
regardez alors que les travailleurs
veulent manifester veulent défendre
leurs droits ils ont affaire à un mur
policiers à des grenades lacrymogènes et
à une réponse violente de la part de
l'état quels sont les projections de
l'état français qui le pousse à acter
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
bien simplement de dire que
l'endettement n'a qu'un temps
aujourd'hui le problème de la france
c'est qu'elle vit au dessus de ses
moyens évidemment c'est le dettes qui
s'accumulent depuis des années si on
choisit de vouloir de s'obliger à leur
rembourser alors que c'est une dette
d'argent magique c'est de l'écriture
alors on doit sacrifier les jeunes
générations on doit sacrifier les
travailleurs à la dette est d'ailleurs
la cades est la caisse d'amortissement
de la dette sociale française a été
prolongée encore d'une quinzaine
d'années alors qu'elle devait voir sa
fin assez rapidement
la cadette c'est simple c'est un outil
qui permet à la france de jouer sur les
marchés financiers sa dette sociale
puisque la dette sociale est un produit
financier qui se vend très bien les
investisseurs adorent acheter de la
dette française plus puisque la france
est encore très bien notée par les
agences de notation mais c'est un cercle
vicieux qui fait que plus on s'endette
plus on doit limiter les dépenses plus
on doit limiter les dépenses sociales en
l'occurrence et plus on doit rembourser
finalement parce que le moment où on
fait défaut et bien là tout tout tout
tout nous tombe dessus on ne peut plus
s'endetter sur les marchés
internationaux
or la france est rentrée dans cette
spirale de la dette permanente et cette
dette prend des proportions tout à fait
pharaonique avec la dette qu'ovide qui
va devenir un poids impossible à gérer
pour l'état français
peu importe ce que nous dit bruno le
maire en réalité ça devient un vrai
problème
gestion à bercy même si on voudrait le
cacher sous le tapis dans les années qui
viennent il va falloir couper dans les
dépenses publiques de manière drastique
ça veut dire des suppressions de postes
ça veut dire la fin aussi de la fonction
publique et du statut du fonctionnaire
avec davantage de contrats privés
davantage de sous traitance au niveau de
l'état et de moins en moins des de moins
en moins d'état social or ce que
demandent les français que demandent les
populations de niveau mondial de la
solidarité
or nos gouvernants font tout pour mettre
d'abord le profit avant la solidarité
alors on entendait eric coquerel de la
france insoumise qui parlait du plus
gros 1er mai depuis longtemps c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
oui il ya beaucoup de monde parce qu'il
y a s'il n'y a pas de convergence des
luttes chilienne confins convergence des
grognes à une convergence aussi des
mécontentements il ya une convergence
loin de ce qui nous est servie
quotidiennement sondage après sondage
sur l'auto satisfecit 1 de ce
gouvernement comptant lui dans la
gestion sanitaire dans la gestion aussi
de du marasme économique et de la dette
qui explose en réalité il y a des
français inquiets des français très
soucieux de leur avenir de l'avenir de
leurs enfants et qui donc vont reprendre
la rue dans dix ans
cette fois-ci peut-être qu'avec le
nombre nous seront protégés parce qu'on
a vu comment ont été traités les gilets
jaunes de manière extrêmement violente
par les préfectures par l'état avec une
répression sanglante qui a fait que les
gens ont peur maintenant de descendre
dans la rue pour défendre leurs droits
leur intérêt donc clairement ce 1er mai
est une des rares opportunités une des
rares fenêtres de tir finalement pour
montrer que il y a encore beaucoup de
monde dans ce pays qui n'est pas
d'accord avec la politique proposée par
le gouvernement qui souhaiterait lui un
autre monde une autre français et ça
compte
avant bien sûr l'échéance politique
l'élection pour les régionales et puis
l'élection évidemment de la
présidentielle en 2022 donc on comprend
qu'il y ait autant de monde dans la rue
aujourd'hui
parce que
rien n'a changé depuis deux ans vous
avez donné le micro à tous et gilet
jaune qui ont battu le pavé samedi après
samedi pour demander toujours la même
chose plus de démocratie plus de justice
fiscale
le droit de vivre dans la dignité le
droit de vivre aussi avec son travail et
d'être traités correctement et bien on
voit que deux ans après rien n'a changé
et qu'on reste dans la même
configuration
malgré malgré ses nombreux appels malgré
le grand débat malgré tout ce qui a été
promis 1
on est au point mort finalement en
france et c'est pour ça que ce premier
met à un 1er mai important comparé au
1er mai d'avant les français sont
suspendus actuellement à deux
calendriers le calendrier vaccinal le
calendrier 2d confinant à parler du
calendrier vaccinal est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est facile d'y voir clair
à ce terrain brillé alors c'est facile
d'y voir clair si si on écoute mails
mâcon tout est limpide 1 on parle du 3
mai du 19 mai puis du 30 juin tout ouvre
c'est formidable on a 20 millions de
doses 30 millions de doses
ça c'est dans le plan rêver de l'énarque
de l'épidémiologiste en chef en réalité
on va voir qu'il y aura sans doute des
complications puisque nous sommes
maintenant aux prises avec de nombreux
variant le variant brésilien le variant
indien le verlan bretons dont on ne
parle plus et que ces vaccins sont
peut-être inefficaces ou moins efficaces
moins loin moins important face à ces
variants donc est ce que ça veut dire et
d'ailleurs vous le voyez il ya un doute
permanent au sein de la population
française on voudrait croire à ces
annonces on voudrait croire au monde
rêvé d' emmanuel macron et on se dit ah
mais on ouvre pour l'été et puis on sera
confiné en octobre comme d'habitude on a
pris l'habitude finalement de ces stop
and go de ses mensonges aussi à
répétition appelez-vous 1
il ya quelques semaines de cela m l'alma
qu'on disait avec tenez encore 4 6
semaines et puis on va ouvrir
on ouvre maintenant potentiellement le
19 mai si tout va bien avec un retour à
l'ordre tous les trois semaines pour
voir si les chiffres n'explose pas on
ouvre alors que les chiffres sont pire
que quand on avait fermé on n'y comprend
plus rien en fait dans cette politique
sanitaire on voit très bien qu'il ya
derrière une volonté de ne pas saccager
l'économie française alors qu'elle est
déjà dans un état catastrophique
les commerçants qui n'ont pas compris de
ne pas être essentiel les lieux de
culture
une centaine de lieux de culture occuper
aujourd'hui actuellement
1 pour défendre le monde de la culture
et les commerçants les restaurateurs qui
n'en peuvent plus et également de ne pas
pouvoir travailler donc emmanuel macron
essaye de ménager la chèvre et le chou
d'avoir ces annonces d'avoir aussi ce
calendrier vaccinal le problème c'est
que la vaccination est lente et que nous
ne savons pas nous n'avons pas encore le
retour sur l'efficacité du vaccin sur le
temps long est ce que si jamais des
variantes se faisait jour comme le
variant indien sai vaccin serait
efficace ça il faudra attendre et on
voit bien que les français aujourd'hui
sont dans l'expectative
il voudrait y croire mais ils sont très
soucieux très inquiet de la suite et
c'est pour ça que le rebond de
l'économie pour ça il faut de la
confiance et c'est le mot qui manque
aujourd'hui les français n'ont plus
confiance dans le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron alors alexis à poullan
on va parler du deuxième cas un rien le
calendrier de déconfinement alors quatre
étapes indus dès lundi jusqu'au 30 juin
avec la levée du couvre-feu
si et seulement si la situation
sanitaire le père mais finalement est-ce
que c'est très clair a aussi bien non
c'est ce que je viens de dire c'est que
c'est très peu clair en fait il y a des
six il ya des conditions
et puis il ya le choix du président de
la république tout est décidé de manière
opaque 1 derrière ce conseil de défense
sous le secret défense avec un aéropage
choisi d'experts qui va appliquer la
politique choisie par un seul et même
mâcon c'est lui qui a décidé d'être seul
face au virus à seuls à nous enfermer
cela nous libérer sa seule politique
aujourd'hui c'est de dire aux soignants
tenez bon aure les soignants ils sont
maltraités ils sont en berne à août ils
n'en peuvent plus il manque toujours
autant de moyens qu'avant on parle
maintenant des suicides au sein de cette
profession qui inquiète
on parle aussi du mal qu'ils ont à
soigner 6000 personnes en réanimation
les chiffres qui continuent d'exploser
et ce discours qui ne suffit plus c'est
à dire qu'il ya d'un côté un discours
mis en scène par la parole
présidentielle et la réalité vécue au
jour le jour par chacun qu'ils soient
commerçants fermaient soignant au bout
de la route malades ducobu ou non
parents parents d'enfants avec les aînés
les classes qui ferment les unes après
les autres et on ne comprend plus rien
parce que il y a eu un problème cognitif
en fait entre ce qui est dit est ce que
nous vivons
et ça devient compliqué parce que je
veux bien la méthode coué c'est
important il faut bien sûr avoir
confiance rester optimiste parce qu'il y
aura une fin bien sûr à cette crise du
coc vide mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'impression que le gouvernement
gouverne nick emmanuel macron un plan il
improvise et ça se voit et c'est
d'ailleurs tout le butin de ces annonces
à répétition de 7 / communication
la semaine dernière il parlait sécurité
il était sur le sommet notre dame il
était avec la bac à montpellier puis il
va voir les élèves en classe de cm2
enfin il parle aux français ils
n'arrêtent jamais de communiqué cette
inflation communicative
elle dit une chose elle dit le vide en
fait stratégique et le fait qu' on
navigue à vue en france sauf qu'il ne
faut pas le dire
et c'est bien ce qu'il en sort c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui la défiance est
présente partout et c'est ce qui risque
d'ailleurs de rendre difficile la
reprise économique vous parlez de la fin
de la crise sanitaire entre center crise
économique selon vous le retour quasi
normal à la vie comme l'a dit l'exécutif
ce sera possible qu'en alors j'ai pas de
boule de cristal mais clairement l'idée
de ce retour à une vie normale qui sera
pas le monde d'avant d'ailleurs puisque
il faudrait être vaccinés chaque année
il faudra garder le pass sanitaires pour
pouvoir bouger dans l'espace changer de
pays allait même au restaurant peut-être
que sais-je encore donc oublions le
monde d'avant nous entrons dans un
nouveau monde un monde de techno
contrôle de biocontrôle avec cette
vaccination permanente avec cette peur
du virus permanente ce monde-là
reviendrait peut-être éventuellement à
la rentrée si si et seulement si la
campagne de vaccination est un succès
s'il n'y a pas de nouveaux variants et
si l'économie peut éventuellement
reprendre mais le mal est fait je crois
que il faut oublier la façon dont nous
vivions auparavant ou alors il faut la
défendre et dire il va falloir trouver
des moyens de vivre autrement de vivre
avec ce virus sans perdre pour autant
toutes nos libertés parce que c'est ce
qui se profile aujourd'hui un état
policier regarder ce 1er mai encadrés
par les forces de police comme jamais la
loi sécurité globale qui voudraient que
nous soyons surveiller de manière
permanente la loi aussi contre le
terrorisme qui fait que maintenant
toutes les connexions internet des
français vont être surveillés par un
algorithme
c'est ce monde là on nous propose à
monde de surveillance permanente avec en
plus ce pass sanitaire qui voudrait que
vous soyez même au point google
gic prêt à aller d'un point b à un point
a et ça je pense que il n'ya aucun débat
ni démocratique ni bioéthique qui a été
mis en place par ce gouvernement et
c'est ce qui m'inquiète et c'est ce qui
inquiète beaucoup
je crois de nos concitoyens oui pas
sanitaire qu'un passeport vaccinale pour
l'instant en tout cas c'est fou on sait
pas vraiment vers quoi on se dirige
non tout est flou mais d'ailleurs quand
c'est flou c'est qu'il ya un loup
on le voit bien d'un côté mais alain
condis ah oui je veux se passe à me
taire et il serait bête de s'en priver
pour les événements de grande ampleur
comme les foires les concerts les
festivals donc là on commence avec ce
passé me taire mais jusqu'où ira-t-il
quelle sera sa durée dans le temps alors
au niveau européen on pousse pour ce
passeport vaccinale depuis des années
c'était déjà dans les cartons dès 2018
ce passeport vaccinale alors que le coe
vie n'existait pas pour dire qu'il
fallait que évidemment on voit si les
citoyens européens étaient vaccinées ou
non pour d'autres maladies et la voilà
ça arrive ça permet d'aller plus vite
thierry breton pousse pour que ce
passeport ne soit imposée dès juin c'est
le cas également en france alors on
commence à rassurer en disant non ce
n'est pas pour aller ni au restaurant ni
au théâtre ni au cinéma rassurez vous
c'est pour aller dans l'avion c'est pour
aller à l'étranger c'est pour aller dans
des foires et des événements de groupe
ça c'est le début mais on n'a ni le
périmètre ni la durée de ce passeport
vaccinale en europe on parle d'un an à
revoir dans 1 ans il faudra l'enlever ou
pas en fonction d'eux ou en est
l'épidémie mais on voit bien qu'on
rentre dans un autre monde et c'est ça
qui m'inquiète c'est la façon dont on le
fait avec une simplicité avec un manque
finalement de garde fous démocratique
qui fait que c'est extrêmement
inquiétant le ni le parlement européen
ni nos parlements nationaux 200 capacité
de poser la question de la raison de ce
passeport vaccinale de ce passeport
sanitaires se passe vers peu importe son
nom même le nom n'est pas n'est pas
claire et de pourquoi vouloir traquer la
population systématiquement dans ce
qu'elle fait au quotidien alors même
qu'aujourd'hui en france on a fait
tomber des digues encore plus grave
qu'on peut ficher les gens pour leurs
opinions politiques ou religieuses c'est
extrêmement grave on est en train de
mettre en place les éléments d'un état
policier et au niveau national et au
niveau européen sans qu' aucun des
parlementaires en place même les groupes
d'opposition finalement sondés
branché on a l'impression qu'ils sont
sans pouvoir ne puisse poser un débat
démocratique nécessaire avant de rentrer
dans de telles solutions draconiennes